what do you see in terms of parallels
for market frenzy bulls and bears
versus uh
versus projects
versus
projects and the life cycle of projects
right right the frenzy of different
films the frenzies of different you know
hot topics even in the media
versus what happens on the trading floor
when people are selling and jumping out
i'll tell you
right a couple of things
somebody once said about um there was
this quote about walk if you're a
soldier walk towards where the shooting
is but a scientist once said you know
run away from where the shooting is and
i often think of it run away from the
crowd
you know i really avoid
once something is it is in uh
certain well-known
technical and culture magazines i
wouldn't touch it with a barge pot i
wouldn't go near it because that's like
the stock market once it's on cnbc
that uh microsoft is going up
that's it game over you know there's no
point in getting into that stock then
and it's i don't mean to make this um
about
uh
that it's all about doing cool ideas or
it's all you know this isn't a cold uh
hard decision this is about being
enthusiastic this is about going into a
project that's going to suck your life
energy
and eventually put it back in your life
energy for a period of time and i have
to i have to love it i have to be
excited about it and i have to know i
can share that excitement now if i go
and do a project which is all being
talked about in last week's wired
magazine some some technical issue
that's in wired magazine from last month
who's going to care about that on a
nine-month time horizon when i do the
project i mean i won't care about it i
want an idea that makes me feel unique
and that communicates to you so it's
it's it's
the best
traders they know what's going to happen
before it happens that's impossible
obviously but they are ahead of the
markets you know they they keep an eye
on the markets they might even the very
best traders and i think you have to be
in a powerful investment bank to move
this you can move the market you can you
know that's a bit like being a
trendsetter i guess with with with films
you know you can actually
you can you can move things the way that
you want to move them if you've got
sufficient capital whether that's in the
markets or in the film business
within reason you know within reason
the markets are huge the viewing public
is huge you can't literally manipulate
the whole market or manipulate the whole
viewing public you've got to be kind of
a little bit more clever than that